is a ketogenic diet appropriate for every cancer patient.
So if you've been with me long enough,
you know the answer to that is no.
So in general, though, doing a keto-like type diet
would be, I guess, appropriate for every person,
period, not even cancer.
You don't want to be eating a lot of sugar.
So when you're eating a ton of carbs,
I know there are carbohydrates,
carbs, you know, root deterians,
all this kind of stuff out there in the world
and you could find some YouTube videos on people
that only eat fruit or only eat grains or I don't know.
I just don't know that that's how we were mentally
and certainly people that are vegetarians
are certainly eating a lot more carbohydrates in general, too.
So, but I would suggest that it would probably
be in the best interest of most people on the planet
to be eating less carbohydrates.
Certainly most people in the United States
since we have been a pharmacolic nation for a long time.
So eating a more of a keto-like diet
to think that keto diet is technically getting in ketosis
to think that we only need to be in ketosis
is I think very incorrect.
Our cells are made to feed off of glucose
and that's how we produce energy.
But for a cancer patient,
to never cancer patient be on a ketogenic diet.
No, I don't think so either,
but again, eating more keto-like
would be more appropriate.